I went to a haunted house yesterday oh
they saw a haunted house experience oh
wait uh yeah because it was Sydney's
birthday right yeah yeah
huh what was it called I can't remember
what it was called it was a scary house
something along those lines but Sydney
was like I've I've wanted to go to this
haunted house it's been made by uh and
this is like my husband listening skills
coming along it was made by some guy who
was famous for doing some ghost stories
in Japan and I was like okay honey we
can go you know I've got a junji maybe
if it was gingito no no no not Junior
okay okay I would know there's another
theme is junji um
he's like a Japanese like TV presenter
who like got famous because uh he told
like a bunch of like really scary
stories and he's like a really good
narrator or something or rather yeah and
I think if I remember correctly he also
like did like a side gig where he like
produced haunted houses or something
like this is my mental bookmark to talk
about the jinjutu anime
didn't tell the story all right we can
we can talk about about that afterwards
but uh yeah I went to and well we went
to a Tokyo Dome and because there's like
a whole kind of like amusement park
there and we've never really I I heard
that was there was a lot of things to do
at Tokyo dome but I never had gone there
to explore what everything there is to
do to do around there the only thing I
know about it is that it was one of the
places that uh that guy took chizuru and
rent a girlfriend and I was just like
that's all I knew about it so all I knew
about it was the ferris wheel you're one
of those people yes yes okay Joey I'm
one of those people okay I know this
place was in anime it was in rent a
girlfriend oh my God this is like real
life yeah but uh they had recently
opened a haunted house experience there
and I don't know you guys like kind of
haunted house haunted house today
recently where I went to yeah yeah one
of the biggest ones right yeah I think
it's the oh I can remember because I was
like it's the biggest and they were like
actually it's the second piece please I
think it's like the second biggest one
in Japan and it's right 40 50 minute
long oh [__] haunted house [__] hell
yeah mine one was like three floors of a
hospital Jesus Christ okay I got to take
Sydney there because mine this one I
went to in Tokyo Dome was only about
like 10 15 minutes
um and it was you know I'm I'm not
really like okay I'm gonna say right
outright I'm a [__] [__] okay to
join the club I hate I just hate the
feeling of being scared and I've never
understood talk to the choir I've never
understood people who just love horror
movies they just go to horror movies
they love being scared yeah I feel like
there's like two feelings I love the
feeling of being unsettled you know like
that's why I love gingito works but I
hate the feeling of just feeling jump
scared little jump scared or like
someone's going to kill me you know I
love ideas that make my mind unsettled
but I hate just the fight or flight
Direction yeah just the direct horror
feeling yeah
um and that's basically everything I
experience in a haunted house I was that
guy who would hate going to any haunted
houses the only reason I went to this
one was because it was Sydney's birthday
I was trying to be a girl that's a good
husband right under any other
circumstance I I ain't going into this
[__] so so paint the scene like what
what kind of like theme was it okay so
it was kind of like The Grudge kind of
kind of thing so they had they had did
yours have like an entire storyline as
well I think it did okay so this this
was did he listen to it yeah I'll be
honest I kind of like wasn't paying too
much attention to the cutscene myself
but the kind of the basic premise was
there was this couple and the guy
cheated on the girl okay and uh
obviously the girl was mad so I believe
that even though the guy cheated on the
girl uh he worked with his side hoe to
just murder the [__] and uh he came
back and buried them and here's his they
did a like a five IQ move they buried
them underneath a kotatsu that's
I don't know why you would bury I don't
know why you would bury the girl in your
own I know it's like negative yeah I
know I know Japan Japanese houses have
like small backyards but I'm pretty sure
it's still big enough to bury your body
yeah right right and so obviously they
got cursed and uh they for wow
they got cursed and uh to remove the
curse
um the I believe the girl that uh he
cheated on with uh no matter what she
did she she had uh half her face was
like burnt off with a curse or something
like that and you had to apply makeup to
to the girl to remove her curse and that
was that was setting the scene that was
the uh that was kind of like that was
like kind of like the final object like
crayon you gotta like what are you you
got it you got to do this yeah collect
the mascara yeah yeah so you have to
like uh there was some makeup and you
had to like puff like the girl's face
with makeup too
so yeah that was the basic premise of
the haunted house
I've never done a Japanese haunted house
experience before because my experience
with haunted houses were kind of like
just in like America or the UK you kind
of either sit on a cart or you uh kind
of just walk through and it's not really
any storyline it's just kind of like
here are some jump scares here's here's
a bat that flies out of nowhere yeah you
know
um so I I did enjoy the fact that there
was this entire narrative that they kind
of took you through from like the
beginning of like you you saw the entire
murder kind of like take place you saw
them hide the body and then kind of like
the entire the entire process of the
girl coming out haunting them and then
also like kind of like killing them and
so the entire house becomes slowly more
and more haunted as it goes along what I
did like about it was that there weren't
too many jump scares there was there was
like two jump scares out the entire
thing and it was like kind of like and
then the entire floor was just booked
out and every room had a different
different
piece of the storyline and halfway
through you know you you find
you find the girl which is obviously
just a mannequin of the girl and uh you
have to pamper her face with her uh with
the makeup and I was just like I've seen
this movie before Sydney you do it you
do it Sydney
I'm gonna die if I do it I I ain't gonna
be that dude that dies I ain't touched I
ain't going near that face yeah I was
expecting like the biggest kind of jump
scare when you like touch your face I I
think that was a fake out because
actually I I don't want to spoil too
much I guess but actually like uh that
that wasn't where the jump scare was
because I was like [__] myself being
like I was like when Sydney touches the
faces Something's Gonna [__] happen
something loud noise or something loud
noise something but nothing and because
there wasn't a jump scare I don't know
if that was worse or better you know
because you know when you expect a jump
scare and it doesn't happen
um that's that's like it it there's a
part of your emotion that's just like
some something's off here it's it's
gonna come later
but uh one thing I noticed is that
everyone working in this haunted house
just was so friendly and had the biggest
smile on their faces and I could kind of
see why afterwards because of the the
biggest jump scare so most of this
haunted house was made with animatronics
right most most of the characters and
the ghosts were just different
animatronics and it was it was like yeah
it's kind of not that scary yeah it's
it's it's kind of junky I mean I should
have known when I saw the ride and it
was like anyone six and over can come
into this haunted house and I was like
if it's like if it's suitable for a
six-year-old how how bad could it be but
there was one moment where where the it
did involve I guess a real person okay
right and I guess this person's job was
just to come out of this one point of
the haunted house I'd just scare the
[__] out of people and I'm like honestly
that sounds like a really fun [__]
job yeah right you're basically just
Sully from Monsters that's literally
like you're like scared yeah yeah I also
want someone watch that movie he's like
damn that that doesn't sound like that
was fun yeah yeah yeah yeah
so like right at the end you're
presented with like this big statue and
it's like oh it's just another janky
animatronic then out of [__] nowhere
appears the only human or ghostly thing
that you've seen this entire uh this
entire thing and yeah it scared the [__]
out of me because I wasn't expecting a
real like human being luckily luckily
like they didn't touch you or they
didn't grab you or anything because I
swear to God I wouldn't I would have
punched anything yeah
I think my survival is that's when it
comes I don't know what everyone's
safety they don't touch yeah just get
close to you yeah they got really pretty
close but that but that's what I like
about like especially like Japanese
horror right it's because it's like it's
that whole thing of like you know not
expecting the unexpected right of of the
whole thing of like oh they set it up to
be like this jump coming up in this
particular scene get ready for it and
then they don't give it to you yeah and
then what that leaves you with is this
like unsettling feeling of just being on
the edge of your seat the entire time
being like well [__] if it's not on the
obvious spot yeah then where the [__] is
it yeah right and I think that's why
like as much as I don't like horror
movies or like horror games and stuff
like that I [__] with a lot of like
Japanese horror like movies because
right they're so they're so good at that
like that building that's just like the
original Ring movie have you seen that
one yeah yeah like there's the one scene
where they just like there's this music
building up and it's like slowly zooming
in and like you know horror movie Trope
yeah there's gonna be a jump scare at
the end of it yeah but then there's
nothing and so what that does is that it
leaves you hanging and just goes well
[__] now I don't know where the jump
scare is and I'm afraid the entire time
even through scenes that where they're
just casually talking right right and I
feel like you know that's what you kind
of experienced in that Japanese haunted
house because I was kind of the same
like I've been to like one or two
haunted or I was dragged into one or two
haunted houses in Australia yeah and
it's like yeah here comes a zombie oh
here comes another thing oh here comes
something popping out of the closet yeah
yeah it's like all right well they
they're normally like on the back of
trucks yeah right right like the
carnival things yeah folded out oh so
they're like I don't know how they make
it but like they're like really quick
it's like six dudes just shout at you I
could you know and I could have just
gone home and got that yeah right you
gotta here yeah but the the one in Fuji
Q is really good I think it's like
that's the scariest one right it was
[__] it was insane yeah like I had
never been to a haunted house where I
felt felt like every single detail was
kind of off the chart is that the one
where it's like every five minutes
there's an emergency exit in case people
want yeah every five minutes
were you scared going through it I mean
like the jump scares are kind of scary
um I was definitely Hamming it up for
the camera I obviously of course I'd
have to say that but like I I you know
it's a kind of a boring video if I'm
just like kind of casually going yeah
all right this is cool I mean like
you you know there's only like a few
ways they can really scare you I I was
more like I was just super impressed
with like the detail and also how kind
of [__] up it got like there's rooms
with like dead babies yeah torn open and
like bodies like full [__] up like
yeah did Kojima produce this it's good
it's no joke you go into this one room
because it's like an abandoned Hall I
think the whole the story they said I've
been listening to it because I mean it
was in Japanese and also I was trying to
mess with the camera is work yeah um and
also we learned a lot of film the story
but I mean you know the story generally
was like some people went to this
hospital it was abandoned and they went
to see it and then they got lost in
there and now you're going in again and
and like dude it was like I imagine if
you like haunted houses this is probably
like the Apex like this was like imagine
it like a whole Hospital they'd kind of
they just built this building and every
single room was insanely well like
themed and built uh even like the office
rooms were terrifying yeah only [__] the
dust is off the charts I'm gonna
contract something but like I mean it
was crazy I mean if Sydney like the one
and two I'm sure she'd loved one of Fuji
cute yeah you have to book it I think
separate from your ticket and in advance
right oh it's kind of annoying because
it's like you get the ticket and then
you pay another 16 bucks to go into this
just the haunted house but you said it's
like well like an hour experience right
um if you're fast I imagine it can be
like 20 30 but if you're taking a sweet
time originally it's like I've seen park
rides yeah I'd rather take my sweet time
especially in the heart attack
experience because yeah I mean like yeah
I've seen my video it's crazy it's so
crazy yeah I mean I would love to I mean
I wouldn't love to but I'm sure Sydney
would I don't know why she loves horror
movies so [__] much I swear she's
watching a new horror movie every year
she is I don't know she's like dog [__]
though he watches like straight to not
even DVD like straight to like oh yeah
straight to VHS straight to the garbage
movie